Barack Obama officially became America's
first black president in January 2009 at
his inauguration so help you God so help
me God
congratulations mr. practice afterwards
the Atlantic's Donaghy she coats rose to
prominence earning a reputation as one
of America's best writers on race you
want Award for his essay fears fear of a
black president and the case for
reparations his 2015 book between the
world and me explored what it means to
be black in America it topped the New
York Times bestseller list and one coats
the National Book Award for nonfiction
he's got a new book it's called we were
eight years in power and American
tragedy
it features essays analyzing the Obama
presidency and the rise of President
Trump tana Hussey Coates
is a recipient of the prestigious
MacArthur Fellowship fellowship she's
trying to say welcome back to the table
mr. Coates thanks for having me back so
let's start with this because you say
you never in your lifetime thought that
you would see a black president in
office and you also say in 2008 many
people thought that Barack Obama could
not be president in 2016 many people
thought Donald Trump could not be
President yet you believe the two are
connected how the two presidencies are
connect well I'll just say I belong to
both camps by the way so I'm kinda I
should be out of the prediction business
by now I I don't think Donald Trump's
presidency is is literally possible
without the response I should say to
Barack Obama not so much Barack Obama
himself and I don't mean that in a
particularly symbolic way his political
career actually begins in birtherism
regrettably birtherism had a high degree
of purchase in the opposition party in
Barack Obama's opposition party during
his presidency upwards of you know
majorities pluralities however you want
to have it of Republicans believe that
he was not a legitimate president I
think Donald Trump had the wisdom if you
want to call it that to see that you
know that that was not you know some
fringe movement that it actually could
be the basis of launching a successful
political career which he did so you
think in part the vote for Donald Trump
was in in part if not a significant part
a vote against Barack Obama yeah and and
I think it was the kind of revanchist
and I would emphasize in part to an
important part but but in part
I think it was a kind of revanche ISM
you know against this idea against the
very symbol is about having a black man
you know lead the country and to some
extent like we should expect this you
know we have a very very long and
regrettable history in this country of
racism and white supremacy the
expectation that with the election of a
black man to the white house that would
somehow disappear that we would no
longer have to grapple with that that
some important percentage of this
country wouldn't be grappling with I
think is a bit naive and it's an
subtitle of your book is called an
American tragedy
the tragedy is that it served as as a
lever to introduce and allowed Donald
Trump to succeed yeah and not just
succeed I mean you know had Donald Trump
come in succeed to the presidency yes
yes yes but how do you even you know
coming to the presidency and as people
said you know I guess shifted and become
presidential maybe the subtitle would be
a little different but instead you know
you cut on your TV and you see a
president going into you know a region
of this country that has just been hit
by a natural disaster and lofting paper
towels instead of audience you see a
president conducting policy via tweet
that's what you say that uneasy at the
same time you have general mattis
suggesting that we should stay in the
Iran deal you have people saying we
should stay in the Paris of court they
have not been able to repeal Obamacare
yet a lot of things that he stood for
fought for there are hallmarks of his
success have been resistant so far right
but it's not a tragedy yeah that doesn't
give me much comfort though because
that's what he tried it like I don't
think it's because of I don't credit
Trump with the fact that Obamacare
hasn't been repealed yet I don't believe
we're in the Paris climate Accords in
anymore I might have missed you know
something there but I don't think we are
I know you know the Iran bill hasn't
been repealed yet but I just I don't I
don't take much conference I don't
credit Trump it's more cultural to
ylönen that's part of it yeah that's
part of one of the criticisms the
president Trump is receiving now is that
he's not in the campaign trail any mode
in campaign trail mode anymore and yet
he does in some people's opinion seem to
cater to only his own voters and and his
group of supporters President Obama was
criticized by some by saying that while
he may have been president for everyone
he wasn't doing enough for the African
American community
so can you square the two and looking
back do you think President Obama made
some missteps with regards to the
african-american community now seeing
what president Trump's being accused of
doing yeah I think black people in this
country make up I believe 13 14 percent
of the population Trump let's thought up
with the paper saying yeah
Trump's base is a lot bigger you know
and so the number of people the sheer
number of voters that you know that he
could consider his base and get away
with appealing is a lot larger than
Barack Obama I think that imposes you
know some degree of power Obama always
had to find some way to somehow
represent the community he came from and
speak to a broader country at the same
time now now there were people like me
who you know was somewhat frustrated you
know but some of those attempts and how
that came up but I was never unaware of
what that meant and with that conflict
man how special of a person frankly you
had to be to walk both lines like that
you were Syrians this really is an amaz
to Barack Obama the book yes I wouldn't
say that a lot of it is I wouldn't go
that far
you feel strongly about him I do I do I
do I also called him to task to I have
yes that's why I wouldn't say it's an
homage you know that's part of it you
know I certainly have you know credit
him for certain things I think he was an
extraordinary individual I was not you
know always a fan of you know how he
addressed african-americans you know and
how he talked to the community but can I
just say this about you you're being
called one of America's best writers on
race and then I heard you gagged when
you heard that I'm gagging right now
okay would you prefer to be called the
black public intellectuals like that
better
no no what would you like yeah I'd like
one day to be the best writer in America
five nine three why no yes I have no
problem with being black I could have no
problem with being a black writer I take
great pride in that but I think when
people say things like you're the best
writer or race it's to pretend as though
I'm not in competition with any other
right I think we can all agree you're on
the path to being one of the ten easy
coach congratulations we all agree on
that well we were eight years in power
and American tragedy is available now